let's talk about the story here we got
from The Intercept Twitter aided the
Pentagon in its covert online propaganda
campaign internal documents Show Twitter
whitelisted sent com accounts that were
then used to run its online influence
campaign abroad check this out they say
Twitter Executives have claimed for
years the company makes concerted
efforts to detect and thwart
government-backed covert propaganda
campaigns on its platform behind the
scenes however the social networking
giant provided direct approval and
internal protection to the U.S
military's network of social media
accounts and online personas
whitelisting a batch of accounts at the
request of the government the Pentagon
has used this network which includes U.S
government generated news portals and
memes memes in an effort to shape
opinion in Yemen Syria Iraq Kuwait and
Beyond let me just stress it may be
indirect but this means the
psychological operations were targeting
American citizens as well you cannot go
on Twitter with a fake middle eastern
account claim the U.S is doing something
they're not and not expect that to
impact U.S citizens this in my opinion
is seditious that the US government is
running influence operations impacting
its own people that should not be
allowed but when we learn that they're
actually providing let's just call
called reimbursement to Twitter for
Twitter engaging in acquiescence to
their to their requests it's a
subsidiary Twitter is allowing the the
US intelligence agencies to run
psychological operations it's being
exposed it was exposed a while ago it's
getting exposed even more today this is
confidence building to me and there's
something else that I think is rather
confidence building that
um I learned thanks to Media Matters
because they wrote this big smear about
this show and they were like uh a 2022
breakdown of all of Tim castiral's
bigots the guests and they're like
they're ragging on Adrian Curry and
Michael magu malice and it's just like
they're making up lies but one thing
they pointed out was that the yay
interview was the number one live show
on YouTube at that moment and so I was
like oh I didn't know you could track
that so I'm tracking it right now and
we're currently number two on YouTube
number one is a Weather Channel report
on the coming blizzard which I can
respect everybody needs to know about
that but then I realized that we are
consistently the top spot on YouTube and
then I thought to myself
if this show can call out psychological
operations can call out Epstein and what
was going on with that and Maxwell yo
the the the sweater is unraveling the
thread has been pulled if this really is
consistently a top live show on the one
of the biggest social media Platforms in
the world I think we're breaking through
and the narrative is crumbling and
that's evidence this is the
counterculture we're burning the
simulation and we need to create it's
just a stable system because things are
going to change things are changing
right now and it's gonna the US is no
longer gonna be the hegemon on Earth we
need to help create an environment where
people can live in peace and and calm
well the truth resonates with people and
the truth has a lot more power than some
State propagandist bureaucratic Becky
sitting at our office eating her potato
chips and spreading some bull crap lies
in order to bomb yemeni's children in
hospitals and schools and and with the
psyop of this story we're number one now
okay we surpassed the weather we're
going to change that good looks but but
this Pentagon Psy up program is against
I've been screaming about psyops for for
so many years they've been denying it's
been happening they're saying no there's
no way we can't be doing propaganda on
the American people Barack Obama signed
the law and I remember talking about
this law specifically with him signing
to directive saying that propaganda
could be used against the American
public I remember covering this the
corporate media responded no that's not
going to happen no way it's happening it
happened and with the U.S pentagon
running psyops on unsuspecting American
people promoting the war in Yemen is
absolutely Insidious and your tax
dollars are literally doing PR for Al
Qaeda because when you look at the war
in Yemen it's the U.S Saudi Coalition
literally bombing the hootsi rebels
creating a humanitarian crisis millions
of people have been displaced tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of people have died because of disease
because of lack of clean drinking water
and the United States is working with Al
Qaeda this is even according to the
Associated Press in order to go after
the hootsies that are aligned with Iran
the Sunni wahhabis with Saudi Arabia are
literally doing staged PR photo shoots
in Yemen the United States is helping
their bombing campaign Jared kushner's
helping Saudi Arabia get better weapons
deal in order to help spread and cause
and and inflict one of the worst
humanitarian crises on the world right
now and that's the war in Yemen and and
truly this is a big issue that deserves
a lot more because they're they're
running propaganda to promote war in
Yemen of all places that that is absurd
what do they want in Yemen
to appease Saudi Arabia are they trying
to like take control of the gulf or
something they're they're very very
surface level rudimentary thing is
there's ideological conflict between
certain yemenis Rebel groups and Saudi
Arabia and Saudi Arabia wants to crush
them and the US is helping them do it
and it's causing a major humanitarian
but it's like right they're releasing by
the Gulf of Aiden I want to look at the
map where is Yemen it's like I don't
know better Loop because uh my
understanding is quite rudimental yeah
they want to control the Gulf of Aiden
is what they want they want that trade
route in the in the Suez Canal that's
why they have Israel where it's at the
liberal economic order wants control
It's a larger proxy war between Iran and
Saudi Arabia so the United States is on
the side of Saudi Arabia they're on the
side of the Sunni wahhabist uh the CIA
uh uh you know people in Iran are the
ones that are usually the victims of
this kind of uh larger attack and this
and and they go back and forth there's a
lot of history here and it's all about
who's going to have the sphere of
influences Saudi Arabia and Iran are two
major oil producing countries and they
both have a lot of power they both have
a lot of resources the United States is
trying to choose a winner but Saudi
Arabia is literally going to China and
saying we're going to expand our ties
here we're going to have better security
relations we're going to have better
military relations we're going to have
better trading relations with each other
which essentially is screwing over the
U.S petrol dollar which is also involved
here
I say uh yeah if I think if uh Iran were
to control Yemen then they would they
would have control of that that golf how
do you I I just want to say like it's
remarkable to me I'm sitting here
listening I see Kyle it's just so
incredibly esoteric the things we're
talking about it's very very in the
weeds I just want to give a shout out to
everybody watching you guys have you
give me such inspiration that we can
talk about like yemeni's conflict and
humanitarian crisis and psychological
operations and have the top streaming
show on YouTube this is this is a white
pill model I just got to say that I keep
I'm sure you guys are listening I'm sure
you guys talked about it already but I
keep thinking about uh everyone at
America Fest applauding like the
anarchist
it was really incredible you know like
there's so many different people with
different thoughts at that place and uh
and seeing you guys on that stage is
really inspiring Kyle Luke saying
abolish the FBI and everyone's going
crazy I'm like I've been saying this for
15 years but now okay I'll take it
someone wrote in in the YouTube video
for that uh live stream that we did
saying that quote I can finally hear the
crowd that look is always hearing in his
head and that's absolutely true
I have hard I go psychote about this
stuff from time to have a Kyle have you
like psychologically how do you stay
calm and like have you been dealing with
not only what you've been going through
personally because you've been also a
personal Whirlwind in a lot of ways that
I'm not and in addition to the
geopolitical state like what do you do
to stay calm and focused
you know
I
I like uh I like spend time with my
family and dog and my girlfriend and
that keeps me pretty level-headed insane
but I don't
I don't dwell on like what's happening
currently on the outside in the world
like I focus on and I look at it but I
don't let it keep me up at night because
they kind of forced you into it you know
that that too they did force me into it
but but how did you uh how did you end
up deciding to to go out you know that
fateful night and uh provide first aid
and do what you did I mean certainly you
had to have seen something happening in
the world around you
well I was down there cleaning graffiti
providing cleaning graffiti and then I
met with the business owner and then we
talked to them I offered my assistants
to help protect the business and then he
said we'll let you know later and then a
friend at Nick Smith called and he said
hey can you come help us protect this
business me and Dominic black said sure
went down there proof it protected the
business put out fires got pepper
sprayed
um and then I got attacked it so it
wasn't even something like where you had
been watching the news I knew what was
happening and I I knew it was really
disturbing what was happening like they
were burning cities down yeah and nobody
was really reporting on it they were
saying they were peaceful protests but
this this is I think a really really
good example you you're probably the
biggest example of someone being forced
into it but for a lot of regular people
minding their own business saying I
don't want to be involved one day they
look outside and they see you know a guy
ramming his car down a parade or they
see people setting fire to buildings and
then whether you want to or not you're
in it yeah
um look at the walk that just reminded
me look how the media treated the ah
where was it the Waukesha parade attack
exactly they said it was the SUV's fault
and I was just like ridiculous why can't
the media just report on what is
happening what is at what they're
actually doing instead of just making it
look better than it actually is you know
I'd like to believe that it's because
good people are secretly being ruled by
a collective of lizard people who have
taken human form and are running the
media but that's just clearly not true
it's just a lot of people believe these
conspiracies it's easier to believe than
the fact that some people are evil
people don't want to believe that their
fellow man would try to destroy
everything just for a little bit of
power but if they're conservative they
absolutely railroad them they put them
through these trials and then these do
they do these cruel and evil things to
them they censor them and they take away
their voice and they put them on
Blacklist yep and then if you're a
leftist you're put up on a pedestal and
then oh you know he's just having a bad
day or he's look at look at look at the
uh Twitter recently I love this antifa
counts are getting banned you know uh
journalists who are doxing are getting
banned and they keep lying about it and
they actually I I love this so much they
gave themselves their own encyclopedia
entry called Thursday night Massacre
because they got suspended one time
temporarily and they called it the
Thursday these journalists have
narcissistic personal disorder to an
extreme degree these journalists out
here they're like like look at you
because of some of these people they've
leaked your address I don't know if they
leaked it but they they obviously they
know where you live two guys showed up
they got shot at long story short oh
interesting that's right you know these
in the these independent journalists not
independent there's a lot of great but
these journalists out here who are going
out spreading false narratives and then
complaining that they're getting banned
off of Twitter
when they're like look at Elon Musk look
at that guy who jumped on his car
because he got suspended thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time